a lot of uh investors in general but
certainly in crypto they attempt to over
intellectualize their Investments and
then they end up missing something like
Bon it's it's gone up like
45x and so there's this there's this
pushing pull between folks that want to
over intellectualize their Investments
to justify it but when you see a trade
opportunity or you see a network that's
about to just explode or something
that's going to go viral and you can
invest in that I mean to me you have to
take a shot at something like that and
so on the spectrum of you know Bitcoin
as a meme versus something like Bon on
the other end of the spectrum there's no
doubt that that uh Bitcoin has in the
certainly in the early days benefited
from internet culture and the memes and
the the kind of virality around uh this
new
asset all right guys bang bang I've got
Joe here Joe you've got this fascinating
thesis that a lot of the chaos and cisis
that's going on on the internet the
things that the Boomers and the Wall
Street kind of Legends they all hate is
actually a real thing it's not just a
joke and whether this is the meme coins
or Internet culture describe a little
bit about what's happening on the
internet and how that's intersecting
with finance and why you're spending so
much time looking for Investments that
really maybe mask it's just internet
culture yeah I mean it's it's a great
question because and it's something I
thought about for quite some time
because the phenomenon of a meme coin uh
is is it doesn't make any sense to like
a fundamental investor or like if you go
get an MBA at a Chicago business school
like they are definitely not teaching
you about this right but there's
something intrinsic about the culture
that exists online that exists on the
internet and you know the kind of that
the joke that I use is similar to what
the Supreme Court Justice said about you
know pornography is that you know I
don't know how to describe it but I know
it when I see it and that's the same
concept with internet culture is that
you can you can just kind of get a sense
right from memes or something going
viral or how things you know kind of
propagate throughout the broader
internet um is a very powerful force and
I think prior to crypto there really
wasn't a way to kind of invest in
Internet culture and now there is um the
you know the the way that I described
meme coins in general is they're kind of
like a derivatives contract associated
with internet culture and there is no
real fundamental analysis that goes into
something like this you're you're just
participating in culture in a way that
other people are as well and you know
this of course started off with Dogecoin
which was a fork of of Bitcoin proof of
work Network and it was a literal joke
right and it went up to I think $85
billion market cap at the 2021 Peak it
is unbelievable right for something
that's supposed to be a joke I think
investors should take something like
this seriously and Shino same thing went
up to about a $45 billion $42 billion
market cap in the last run it was
supposed to be ethereum Dogecoin killer
and most recently U with the rise of
what's happening with all of the
activity on salana there's one on a
Solon called Bonk and and Bon what's
interesting about the Bon story whereas
Dogecoin was a joke shenu was supposed
to be this Dogecoin killer Bon actually
like saved Salon defi right so a lot of
people don't understand the story behind
this on Christmas Day 2022 they aird
dropped this token to loads of wallets
and a lot of these wallets were deved
Vel opers on salana and some of those
folks live in um I would say
economically challenged areas where a
$10,000 airdrop is worth quite a bit of
money and it enabled a lot of these
developers and Builders and creators to
keep building and creating on the salon
um Network while you know the the the
kind of Fallout from FTX and everything
else that had happened in 2022 and Salon
was you know trading like eight or n
dollar right since then um you know Bon
has
actually shipped products um what's
interesting about Bon to me is that uh
you actually have like this super
high-powered startup wrapped in a meme
or culture coin and uh they have
multiple products that they've shipped
um the team recently did this uh 12 days
of Bonk Miss where they got more people
you know utilizing other aspects of the
salon ecosystem and these are these are
guys that you know they just got
together and said let's try to you know
kind of re revamp and restart the the
interest and passion behind salana and
it's working I mean uh Bon is literally
the most integrated project throughout
all of salana and I have a lot of
startup investments in salana and Bon is
by far the most integrated and most
recently I'll just kind of leave you
with this why I think you know there's
there's something different about the
evolution of meme coins or culture coins
is on Christmas Day U you know know Bon
has this telegram trading bot called bon
bot it did more transactions per second
than the entire ethereum L1 uh they're
now generating real Revenue protocol
Revenue more so than magic Eden which is
a billion- dollar startup nft
marketplace right so this is not your
average meme coin right this is
something that has real kind of value
and passion behind it that I think a lot
of people are just starting to wake up
to what are people doing on it are they
just trading it back and forth and it's
kind of like you know a joke oh let me
send it to my friend that's a joke and
send it back or are people actually
using it for some sort of utility
outside of just you know the joke or the
meeme coin itself yeah I mean it's a
good question like there's there's lots
of stuff you can do with it um because
all of the kind of you know the projects
and protocols uh and applications that
exist within the salana ecosystem and by
the way Bon is on you know multiple
chains at this point but they started on
salana um you know it's like hey go try
out you know this pers exchange you can
do some stuff with Bon there or go park
you know uh some Bonk in a in a
liquidity pool here or there's this new
project Goose effects that has a
single-sided liquidity pool just park
Bonk in there and earn interest on it uh
there's Bonk Integrations into video
games that are um built on Solana so
it's almost like this um it's like a uh
like the this the social lubricant for
people to get exposed and experience
with salana and they have like in
addition to that they have really good
products so yes I mean are people
trading it back and forth and and
swapping and this and that of course but
they're doing that with all kinds of
tokens right and I just think that
something uh like Bon has this unique um
uh quality to it that enables it to be
utilized well beyond just kind of like
oh I'm buying into like the greater full
theory of the next Dogecoin because I'm
actually learning about the products
that exist on salana so what's
interesting to me is is um if I go and I
talk to someone on Wall Street they'll
tell me uh I'm an investor I'm not a
Speculator right I'm not a gambler uh if
I go and I talk to someone in the casino
right in Vegas they'll tell me 100% I'm
gambling they're actually doing the same
thing there is an element of they're
taking risk the probabilities are very
different uh I would not encourage most
people to go to the casino and think
that they're going to win nearly at the
rate that they could win in the stock
market but to a degree the stock market
is a casino as well and and there's
gambling going on it's just kind of I
always joke that like if you wear a suit
tie and have cologne on you call it
something different then if you're
actually just drunk on you know late at
night now I will bring that exact same
framework to these meme coins and what I
would say is like to degree Bitcoin is a
meme coin in the sense of there are
memes that surround Bitcoin and there is
an internet culture that surrounds it
it's kind of reinforcing very similar to
what you're talking about here but it
almost feels like it's the one that's
got the suit the tie and the cologne on
it's kind of like broken out and people
would say hey don't call it a meme coin
like it's something else is there more
similarity maybe Than People realize
between you know Bon which seems like on
one one end of the spectrum and Bitcoin
which seems like it's on the other end
of the spectrum yeah I mean the the
analogy you're using of like you know
the guy with clone and suit and tie or
something is doing the same thing as as
the guy smoking a Paul mall at at you
know the casino like it's it's so spoton
because at the end of the day right like
you can dress up investing any way you
want but at the end of the day you're
speculating um you you are speculating
on the future outcome of you know the
cash flows of a company or the value of
a commodity or whatever that may thing
May actually be you're forecasting some
event in the future so that you can make
money that's basically gambling right
now we don't want to call it that
because hey these guys get paid a lot of
money to manage people's money right and
and they gotta maintain that that P
Persona um I think the other thing is is
that a lot of uh investors in general
but certainly in crypto um they attempt
to over intellectualize their
Investments and then they end up missing
something like Bon which you know
my fund full disclosure we we've been an
owner of Bon for quite quite some time
now and it's it's gone up like
45x uh in the past two months and so you
know are you how do you explain that to
your LPS how do you explain that to your
investors to say something to the extent
of like well you know it's just this kid
thing and it doesn't really have any
fundamental value it's like right but it
went up like 50x and you know if you
have a concentration risk policy like
any you know risk manager would you
can't blow up you know buying 2% of your
AUM in in a in a meme coin right and so
there's this there's this push and pull
between folks that want to over
intellectualize their Investments to
justify it right we're seeing a lot of
this right now in the ethereum ecosystem
um and we've saw we've seen it in
Bitcoin as well in the past but when you
see a trade opportunity or you see a
network that's about to just explode or
something that's going to go viral and
you can invest in that I mean to me
you have to take a shot at something
like that and so on the spectrum of you
know Bitcoin as a meme versus something
like Bonk on the other end of the
spectrum there's no doubt that that uh
Bitcoin has in the certainly in the
early days benefited from internet
culture and the memes and the the kind
of virality around uh this new asset um
it has now certainly grown up right
thank you Black Rock and bitwise and
everybody else that's that's doing their
part um but at the end of the day it's
still is absolutely I mean it's a
digital asset right it is it is crypto
it is internet native digitally native
and uh I think it's fair to say that it
is probably on the more you know uh
adultlike version of the meme coin um
but it is absolutely uh has has
characteristics that are consistent with
most meme or culture coins now when I
see these coins that are so asymmetric I
know the fund itself is called
asymmetric right but um it almost feels
like the opportunity cost or definitely
it's true that the opportunity cost of
not buying is higher than buying and
missing how does that change portfolio
construction right because now all of a
sudden you're not doing you know cash
flow analysis and trying to figure out
and uh build a portfolio in the same way
that you would where maybe there's a 20%
downside and a 2X upside check out 45x
upside 1X downside and so how does that
change you know the way you all actually
think about allocating Capital out of a
fund this episode is brought to you by
aradon there are a brand new startup led
by a number of Silicon Valley Legends
who just raised $81 million to build the
future of Internet infrastructure you're
probably wondering what that means let
me explain there are numerous new
disruptive technologies that are being
adopted simultaneously from blockchain
to artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Technologies thrive in
this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
Bitcoin miner powered by the the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these air cooled singlephase
and dual phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
they've Superior uptime and they
leverage a brand new innovation called
Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
aradine
that's a a d i ne.com go check them out
at radon.com today yeah I mean look this
is something that myself and and my team
uh kind of debate internally a lot uh is
portfolio construction and it has a lot
to do with you know how we view the
broader market right so we launched the
fund in June of 2022 uh very interesting
time to be launching a crypto fund uh
and we were bearish right we had a very
bearish Outlook um interest rates and
then the kind of you know every month
there seem to be a generational crisis
happening in crypto it's not really when
you want to be long right um we
obviously fli that at the beginning of
this year and uh uh have benefited from
that and have gotten you know full-blown
um you know bull bull bull market
sentiment since uh you know call it mid-
October late October um how does that
relate to the composition of our
portfolio so first you know asymmetric
we have an early stage VC fund so you
know with those it's your standard you
know early stage Venture Capital
startups you know tokens Equity Etc
let's just talk about the hedge fund
because I think that's the important
part that we're discussing here so hedge
fund look we're we're a long short
multistat directional excuse me
discretionary hedge fund uh our job is
to make money for our LPS and if we see
trade opportunities we put them on we
are not married to trades myself and my
trading partner have over 45 years of
combined trading experience with
billions under management this is not
new to us the key with crypto is that
when a lot of folks especially from
trafi get into it they can't stomach the
V the volatility and we love V in fact
uh when there's no volatility like
that's actually when we do like the
worst which is just smaller returns when
there's V we eat it up and so a lot of
this has to do with how we construct a
portfolio with Majors so whether it's
Bitcoin ethereum salana Etc and how we
express that not just through spot
tokens but also through what we we see
is like complex options structures that
are wildly mispriced consistently
throughout the the crypto Market but
then on the flip side what is an example
of one of those yeah sure so um let's
say I'm trying to think of something
that I I won't expose our positions but
um here's an example actually in
December of last year when salana was
kind of on the lows eight eight n bucks
we did get very long um the spot asset
but we also put on a a a Costless risk
reversal call spread so what is that we
sold a put um for end of January uh at
about $7 strike for salana where we
would if we got put to it we're buying
salana at like 650 which we would be
buying it anyway but we took that uh
premium in and paid for a $20 by $25
call spread for the end of Jan we had
determined uh with a high level of of
conviction and probability that that was
going to be kind of the range for where
salana could potentially trade from from
a mean reverse new flows coming in etc
etc well that's exactly what happened so
Salo literally traded up to 25 by the
end of Jan we basically pined that call
spread and me it cost us nothing so not
only are we long the underlying but we
get additional juice from a Costless uh
um options trade that uh I think
candidly a lot of folks in crypto um
don't know how to put on um and I think
you see this and this is not a detriment
to any of the other fund managers out
there but most folks don't have you know
20 plus years of trading derivatives
experience they just don't and uh crypto
really will test your metal on draw
Downs if you don't know how to actually
structure things in a hedged way but
also finding ways of benefiting from you
know High volatility environments and so
most recently right like Bitcoin trading
up to 45k ethereum starting to trade up
to 2400 I mean salana just went up to
125 we sell puts and and buy call
spreads consistently because V is so
high when VA is super low we buy VA we
don't want to be we don't want to be
selling VA when it's in the 30s and 40s
we want to be you know selling it when
it's in the 90s and hundreds like
something like salana the last thing
I'll mention on the portfolio
construction side is is you know the
longer tale of assets right so at
asymmetric we have a very uh strict what
we call concentration risk policy that I
think I would think most hedge fund
managers would have but you know we' be
surprised uh where we will never take um
a position on that's more than 2% % of
the funds uh assets under management for
anything that's not a top 20 market cap
coin and the reason we do this is that
uh in the case that we're wrong which
sure we've been wrong in the past with
trades 2% of the a can't blow up the
fund right if you're putting 50% of your
your your funds Capital into something
like Shinu you know like you got a
really good chance of of of blowing up
and so um so number one uh we we have a
concentration risk policy that we adhere
to and number two um it's hardcoded our
limited partner agreement we never take
more than 1X leverage notional ever so
since we launched the fund in June of
2022 pick your benchmark um we are
destroying every Benchmark at this point
and the highest net leverage we've ever
run is a 0. n uh with an average of
about a06 and the reason is is we can a
you know identify opportunities that are
that are great trading opportunities and
then B also find ways of getting what we
call embedded leverage in these option
structures that dramatically improve our
R pnl what type of LPS are drawn to this
right you guys have very interesting
backgrounds you guys have managed macro
funds you know billions of dollars you
can share where you guys worked or or
kind of who was backing those
organizations is it that type of person
right kind of like the more traditional
Wall Street hedge fund type manager
that's interested in what you guys are
doing or are you guys basically having
to go and and find you know crypto
native type folks who are just looking
for more sophisticated ways to get
exposure to the market yeah uh this is
near and dear to my heart because
raising money in 2022 was not fun uh so
you know look it turns out that when uh
I I really didn't have a plan on
launching a fund until a good friend of
mine named stej who's a very successful
U VC you know came to me and he's like
Joe you're you're kind of like the only
guy that understands Tech and trading
that's not out of fund like come run a
crypto fund at at Kindred Ventures his
firm and I said look I'm flattered but
if I'm an entrepreneur if I'm gonna do
something I'm going to do it myself and
he's like I knew you would say that so
he helped me kind of get this the
structure in place and and you know
think about about service providers and
how to how to you know put it together
and and he said oh by the way I
preemptively pitched you to Mark andrion
and Chris Dixon and they want to be the
first money into your fund and I was
like okay you know you kind kind of
don't pass up that type of opportunity
and so since then you know the the kind
of spectrum of of investors is primarily
High Networth family office types that
have uh you know some crypto exposure
but we we just landed you know a huge
fund of funds out of Hong Kong that's
backed by the largest Commercial Bank in
mainland China right so I think lot of
it has to do with now people understand
who asymmetric is what we're capable of
what our returns look like you know how
we manage risk uh how we've managed
through you know arguably one of the
most brutal bare markets in crypto
history to where we are today and so
that Spectrum um uh of investors whether
they're us they're foreign um is kind of
all over the map um what we have not
found no surprise uh I had these guys
verbally committed uh the institutions
right the institutional investors um
clearly you know took it on the chin
last year and uh you know effectively
you know put the pause button on all
forms of of crypto fund managers
especially emerging managers like myself
uh we're comfortable where we're at uh
with what we've been able to do with the
the highly convicted LPS that we do have
of the kind of family office highet
worth as well as fund to funds um but
you know our doors always open to the
institutions as well are they scared
because the asset class itself is new
and seems risky and then when you get
into trading of it and then derivatives
and like you're kind of just compounding
in their eyes risk or what do you think
is holding them back yeah I mean this is
just my opinion it's it could totally be
wrong but I do think that there is uh
there's a couple of things one imagine
you're you know like a a PM or something
at an endowment and um you know you want
to allocate 1% of the AUM to crypto well
if you end up up um investing in
something like FTX you just ruined your
career potentially right and so I think
people got really scared with the career
risk because like you know let's be
clear if you're working at an endowment
it's it's pretty pretty cush gig for the
most part I don't think a lot of people
want to take on that career risk
especially in the United States and the
the headlines have been horrendous uh
for the past you know call it 18 months
they're marginally improving now um so a
lot of folks were just like I don't want
anything to do with it because from a
you know political standpoint the
headline risk the career risk doesn't
make a lot of sense um in addition to
that when you look at you know our our
strategy um you know a lot of these uh
asset managers and institutions you know
they they write massive checks well we
were a smaller fund to start with so
there's a kind of a limitation there
right that's more of a tactical you know
operational thing it's not really the
major blocker I think really people got
freaked out uh from what happened in
2022 you saw a lot of these a lot of
them were in like the big VC funds that
are clearly sitting on mismarked
Investments um and you know they have to
mark those right and so I think you kind
of put all this together and say all
right if if there is a a a c change
event with respect to regulation
headlines you know wall Street's
adoption whatever the thing may be um
they'll probably start to dip their toe
in and to be super clear there are you
know I think you know this as well there
are some institutions that are involved
they're just certainly not seeking out
at least from my perspective currently
crypto fund managers whether on the
hedge fund or the Venture side let's
talk macro um you guys understand it
pretty well you guys have literally bet
billions of dollars in the market on
macro uh I think the like real simple
brain you know explanation is like
interest rates go up all the
goes down um interest rates went up and
crypto went down duh so if interest
rates go down then crypto will go back
up but like not so fast uh crypto
Bitcoin Bonk name your you know whatever
tribe everything's been going up and
interest rates are still high now one
argument is like oh people are just
trying to front run like a Fed pivot but
it seems like maybe there's a Detachment
from like traditional macro and this
industry how how do you think of the
macro overlay and its importance for
some of these assets and and their price
movement yeah I mean great question so
yeah my my trading partner um one of the
best macro guys I know uh manage you
know a billion a quarter at rev powered
Global macro cross asset cross goo is
very very legit and understands the
plumbing of the financial system uh
extremely well and so that of course
factors into how we think about um you
know taking risk as it relates to what
is arguably the furthest out on the risk
curve which is crypto um our view has
been and we've written about this and
and folks can you know subscribe for
free to check this stuff out uh we wrote
back in I think August or September of
last year that we think the FED is
probably going to end up between 5 and
6% and they're going to be done turned
out that that was what so far is the
case now of course there is a chance
that they could hike into 2024 um we
don't see that as a strong possibility
the dot plots recently came out
suggesting I think three hikes in the
back half of the year uh so yes um I
think rates is kind of the obvious one
but then also what does that how does
that impact the dollar uh the dollar
obviously got smoked since the last uh
fed fed meeting and it continues to to
move lower right well that is great for
risk assets um we also look at things
like the equity risk premium uh which
was I think almost negative if not at
zero uh kind of at the when when yields
were at their highs um that has to
revert some in some respect and you've
seen equities kind of rip since then
this is all appetite for risk right and
I think you know a lot of the uh folks
that are allocating to bonds clipping
you know five% plus or four and a half
percent Plus on on your 10 year and 30
years um those
uh you know I those are those are great
trades right like for that allocation of
of what you need but at the end of the
day right like if you're moving back
towards an interest rate environment
that is going to be you know I would say
somewhat accommodative it does not mean
it's going to zero overnight right but
uh the market wants to I think you're
you're right kind of sniff these things
out potentially front run them um do we
get ahead of our skis like what does
that actually do to um asset inflation
which then translates to you know call
it retail or consumer based inflation um
TBD but this is something that we have
absolutely kept a pulse on and when we
started to actually you know crypto has
this unique um I don't know it's like a
spidey sense where in October is you
know leave it to crypto that a fake news
headline is the thing that kicks off the
bull market around the the Bitcoin ETF
it's hilarious um but what we actually
started to notice is some of the stuff
we track internally was like you know we
started to see stable coin flows
actually tick up we started to see flows
into institutional products really tick
up and that hadn't happened for quite
some time that was a difference and so
you know we wrote about this in our
November piece like one of the hardest
things about being a Trader is is
understanding when the market has
shifted where something has changed
because if you've been in this like beat
up bare market for 18 20 months it's
really hard for you to get out of that
mentality be like no no no it's time to
get long right we were able to do that
you know based on sentiment but also
some of the the kind of metrics that we
end up tracking on a macro level but
also very crypto specific
and since then you know we haven't
really seen that slow down we think that
this is we think 2024 is is going to be
a boomer of a year um barring some crazy
exogenous event which we will not
discount to zero uh and a lot of it has
to do with you know the macro
setup now when you start seeing um
Global liquidity it always surprises me
how on one hand we have seen
um the FED take one action but maybe
China specifically has been operating on
the complete opposite end of the
spectrum is it Global liquidity that
really matters or can we think of crypto
as like a us-centric type thing and
maybe the rest of the world is less
important yeah I mean uh this is
absolutely something we track right
there's a really good company out of the
UK called crossb liquidity that this is
all they do uh their reports are
fantastic um and I think one of the the
key misunderstandings around Global
liquidity is that it's not just Central
Bank you know tightening or easing
there's a lot to do with the what they
call the shadow monetary system and um
when that starts to tick up what you
know Shadow monetary system or Shadow
banking system is like you know I think
the the the very sort of egregious way
to think about it is like hard money
lending right some guy has some money he
loans it to you to kind of do something
to fix up a house and flip it or
whatever right that's a that's like a a
rough example of of Shadow monetary
policy or Shadow banking industry that
piece has dramatically picked up uh in
the second half of this year and of
course yes China is is injecting it
seems like records amount of capital
like every other week so yeah that is
going to have an impact and then you
know the other thing that we tend to
track as as it relates to you know
outside the United States specifically
China is capital flight out of China
typically when there's Capital flight
out of China Bitcoin tends to do really
well can you can like draw your own
conclusion as to why that's the case
right um so from our perspective you
know there's the the global liquidity
kind of bottom technical bottom heard uh
in 2022 of last year but we've really
started to see that firm up over the
course of the past few months not just
with say you know um Central Bank easing
policies but really what's happening in
the shadowed monetary system as well
what about shorting in crypto right
that's kind of a key component but when
you have these assets that can be
incredibly asymmetric uh it gets a
little dicey in the macro world we see
short hedge funds closing up shop people
walking away from shorting individual
names and just trying to short baskets
it feels like maybe crypto is like still
the wild wild west of short uh selling
what's going on there this episode is
brought to you by cal.com what do I have
in common with Chad Hurley from YouTube
Toby from Shopify and Alexis from 776
and the co-founder of Reddit we all use
cal.com instead of cly and we are all
early investors as well cal.com is
leading the charge of scheduling
Platforms in the open-source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficiency previously reserved for
League corporations and Tech gurus if
you like to have your calendar organized
and be able to have an efficient
exchange when scheduling but you love
all of the benefits of open- source
technology then cal.com is for you they
are transforming sophisticated calendar
management into an accessible tool for
all via a userfriendly interface you can
customize it and you can make your
calendar work for you use code pomp for
$500 off when you set up your team with
with cal.com today again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time yeah I mean uh
so we have a rule at asymmetric is that
we do not short Tales we buy them uh and
we rarely will short uh uh assets um we
certainly will not short in the face of
a booming bull market um the way that we
actually you know we were actually short
last year heading into October and
November um but we did this through Dirt
Cheap put spreads on bitcoin um that's a
pretty reasonable way of expressing a
directional view to the downside with
effectively Li you know limited um risk
right if you're buying a put spread the
amount of money you spent is what you
can lose
um I I actually have this this this
hypothesis and it's not mine it came
from a friend of mine who who's been in
crypto for a long time um that I think a
lot of people have watched the movie The
Big Short and they want to be right as a
short and the problem with this is is
that well number one like markets are by
definition structurally designed to go
up right so you're you're constantly
fighting this like multi hundred years
force of markets rising and then in
addition to that um shorting has a a
limit amount of upside whereas when
you're long it's you know in theory in
infinity and so there are there's a
desire I think by a lot of folks to like
short the top and and and kind of U you
know Farm the clout engagement from
doing something like that um and you
know from time to time we will hedge
certain positions through whether we're
you know one of the ways that we tend to
do it is we'll sell calls against our
underlying which yeah we're technically
short the call but we're you know it's a
call spread so we're not actually
worried about um you know that the tail
risk there um but when folks just go
naked short in this market um a lot of
it has to do I think with the culture of
crypto trading and wanting to be that
guy that uh shorted the top of some mean
coin or the market or whatever it may be
and time and time again folks just don't
realize that you know the the odds and
probabilities of of being right
consistently on the short side are just
very very slim relative to being right
on the long
side when you're doing this work
um how much of the returns in crypto uh
whether it's long or short is from like
sophisticated people taking money from
unsophisticated people versus no you
actually have a very sophisticated
market and people are just on different
sides of um you know on different sides
of investment thesis or or kind of long
or short yeah this is the old uh left
curve right curve or mid curve right um
so if you guys have seen that Meme uh
look I think that there is there's no
question that there is um a a there's a
movement of what we would we would call
more sophisticated Market participants
entering the market um there's a ton of
unsophisticated Market participants and
what and I think it's it's just because
you know crypto is This Global
phenomenon that basically anybody can do
for the most part and um and of course
the exchanges will enable you to gamble
your ass off right with with all that
leverage um but one of the things that
we look at is uh you know we we tend to
look at um how are options markets
pricing things because in a lot of cases
like you know earlier this year 2023 we
were seeing spot volumes just getting
decimated right the trading volumes were
just super low yet open interest in
volumes on the CME and and other you
know options contracts or options
providers and derivatives providers
we're going to alltime highs like during
like the doldrums of spot volumes being
the lowest they've been in years that
signals to us that there is you know
more demand from what we would call
sophisticated investors or sophisticated
Traders and furthermore the fact that
the CME now has the majority of open
interest for Bitcoin and ethereum
products um you know those are guys that
have to kyc have to you know uh set up
you know with wed Bush or Merck or
something to this this effect to be able
to face the CME that have to fund these
accounts right like these are not you
know call them degens on on the internet
that are able to actually do this and so
if you just look at something like the
CME with respect to volume and open
interest like there's more sophisticated
folks coming right and I do think that
that Trend will continue especially as
you know we see the ETF or ETFs get
approved in in in 2024 um I do think a
lot of the banks are actually going to
really start to unleash you know the the
options trading desks uh and other forms
of of products uh to their customers so
we're all for that because we love
trading options and derivatives um but
as it relates to kind of you know the
the retail folks like I will say uh the
onchain stuff specifically on salana um
but those ethereum and other l1s and l2s
as well uh that's where you see a lot of
um you know I would say severe price
dislocation and fragmentation amongst
the understanding of the market
participants and and and there are very
few sophisticated uh I would say Market
participants that are that are operating
chain
today now one of the last things I want
to talk about is this quote um that you
said full-blown depression or dog coins
to a trillion you got to unpack this for
us because that just seems like such an
absurd uh dichotomy to a degree but also
like maybe that is why it's true yeah um
so yeah I wrote about this in the aetric
market update at the beginning of
December um so I have a friend of mine
and this has to do with you know Meme
coins Bon
specifically um I have a friend of mine
who uh you know runs macro at a very
very large hedge fund um out of New York
and uh we were having this conversation
back in 2022 because the the kind of
aggressive approach that the Fed was
taking with their tightening cycle was
just super intense and and he said to me
he's like you know at some point Jerome
Powell's gonna have to make a decision
does he want a full-blown depression or
does he want dog coins to a trillion and
it just resonated with me so well
because
I do think that as absurd as that may
sound that's where we're going right
like if you take the total you know
market cap of like all meme coins at
this point um they're nowhere close to a
trillion dollars they could get there
right with with enough you know uh kind
of liquidity entering the system risk on
people not wanting to miss the next
shenu or Dogecoin or wherever it may
actually be we could see and by the way
you know Zoomers Millennials to some
extent as well they kind of have opted
out of the Trad traditional approach to
investing because they can't afford it
right and so here's something where
they're like yeah yeah that like uh
house or your you know 41k thing like
irrelevant to me this dogcoin I could
make 100x my money or zero like there's
a huge draw to that type of a investment
if you will and I think a lot of it has
to do with the outcome of what's
happening on macro as ironic as that may
be uh you know if the FED is going to
keep tightening and and more or less
Crush the economy pushing us into a
depression I don't think that's going to
be the case especially an election year
well what that implies then is on the
other side the probability of dog coins
to a trillion I think goes up pretty
significantly outside of Bon outside of
let's call it top 20 market cap assets
what else are you most excited about and
it doesn't just have to be an asset
itself it can be an industry development
it can be maybe even a negative thing
that you're like hey we actually think
that this could happen and it' be a huge
opportunity for us to exploit for for
return what what are some things that
fall into that
category sure yeah so I mean I've been
uh I've been not surprising uh
non-consensus on ethereum l2s for a long
time uh for for quite some time uh and a
lot of it has to do with uh uh you know
there's so many of them there's like 40
of them now um but I I actually go back
to kind of the first principal approach
from the end users perspective you know
um there's a lot of kind of academic
engineering that goes into scaling
ethereum and to be super clear I'm not
anti- ethereum in in any stretch I'm
just looking at it from kind of like an
investment standpoint um they're they're
effectively pushing the scaling out to
these layer twos uh and from a user
perspective you know like you open up a
metamask wallet and like now you got to
switch this network and do I have to
bridge something and like well what if
the bridge doesn't work or there's now
Bridge hacks or what if the L2 uh all of
a sudden inscriptions land on the L2 and
the L2 stop producing blocks like what
do I do that there just seems to be a
lot of challenges as it relates to the
experience right this is not to suggest
that they're not going to solve some of
the you know centralized sequencer
challenges as it relates to l2s Etc so I
think from a trade perspective your l2s
those tokens will do significantly
better than just holding ethereum this
is of course not Financial advice but
that's my view um but I think you know
fundamentally when you're starting to
take you know something that is the part
of the core value of ethereum which is
you know execution of transactions and
pushing it out you're taking value out
of ethereum now on the flip side uh a
couple things that I am excited about
are how to parallelize the evm um this
is a you know Again full disclosure we
we've invested in companies like SE SEI
obviously we're big Salon um Bulls Etc
um there is this this desire to still
utilize uh ethereum's virtual machine
but making it faster and um I'm I'm hand
waving intentionally to not lose folks
and in the technical weeds here but
there's a lot of work and interest
that's that's being done in this space
whether it's you know say it's monad um
it's neon which is a a you know a
project that enables ethereum devs to
kind of use salana as an L2 almost is
the kind of loose way of describing it
so that that area is interesting from an
engineering standpoint now let's talk
about normies I actually am have been
and continue to be the most bullish on
mobile being the big next breakout for
crypto and web
and we saw this you know and call it 20
2009 2010 11 time frame mobile first
applications were there were
applications that literally could only
be on an iPhone or Android device right
we haven't had kind of mobile first web
3 applications yet and I think we're
going to start to see more of that like
we see we saw friends Tech which is you
know was an interesting experiment I
think um not taking anything away from
the team but you know the the product
had a lot left to be desired from a
user's experience perspective right so I
do think mobile has um probably the most
wh space and and growth potential we're
tracking this very very closely at
asymetric uh and so hopefully you know
the next kind of you know call it
billion users if you will that are
already on their phones all day anyway
uh start to adopt it uh crypto and web 3
through you know mobile first web 3
applications now on top of this there's
two other pieces I want to talk about
before I let you go um you have this
tweet that says eth 0 to 1400 to 80 to
4,800 and then you say salana 0 to 260
to 8 to a
th you think it's that simple it just
kind of salana follows the the ethereum
uh path yeah I mean look like uh uh this
gets back to kind of the uh I was having
this discussion with some folks the
other day in a telegram chat about um
you know narratives and then over
anything over fundamentals and um crypto
is heavily narrative driven like let's
be clear you know this is not news to
anybody that's been in crypto it's
heavily narrative driven right and the
thing about like that tweet specifically
and the reason why I I put it out there
is um people are going to see what
happened with ethereum right and and go
I missed ethereum or or now I have a
mandate at my trafi hedge fund to be
able to buy crypto or something this to
this extent you say well if there is
another L1 that has the potential to
repeat history it's probably salana
right and it's and it's that simple of a
view that doesn't require deep
fundamental analysis right it is a
narrative that can be picked up at a
global scale and we're again we're
talking about internet culture here the
virality of this narrative getting
picked up we're already seeing it with
people like uh what's his name r Paul
right like he's a big salana guy and
he's been talking about like the soulle
eth trade the soulle BTC trade it's not
to say that eth and BTC are going to you
know not do well but salana is likely
going to do better because a lot of
these Tailwinds whether it's you know
you new users coming on board you know
salana flipping the Dex volume of
ethereum Salon flipping the nft volume
of ethereum or the fact that there's
this narrative that's floating around
saying like hey ethereum went down to 80
bucks and then ripped to 4,800 Salon
went down to eight bucks who's to say
this thing doesn't go to a thousand I
think that that has been and continues
to be and you see it in the price action
of salana I mean on Christmas Day this
thing was trading more volume than
Bitcoin and ethereum combined on
coinbase right so you see it in the
flows you see it in the narratives and I
really think um you to from my
perspective I I tend to kind of check
myself because I'm like is it really
this obvious and this simple and I think
the answer is yes where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
learn more about asymmetric sure so you
can go to uh I guess x.com jcan or
twitter.com jcan and then asymmetric
Financial uh that's the website and you
can contact us there there's a little
form you can fill out to reach out to us
and then uh if you want to read our free
market updates that we put out every
month um you can go to subscribe. asmm
metric. financial Joe thank you so much
I appreciate it I learned a ton today I
think you got a very unique view on the
market your returns seem to uh show that
there's something that you're thinking
about that seems to be right and so we
definitely do it again in the
future thanks man